either Steve here Steve Kaufman and
today I'm going to talk about an aspect
of fitness which is doing double unders
a form of rope skipping and how that
relates to language learning but first
of all I hope you enjoyed my interview
with Ollie Richards as much as I did and
I did another interview with Lindsay dau
of Lindsay does languages which will be
up I think next week sometime but i just
wanted to do this one because it's
something that came up um double unders
they are a form of skipping skipping
rope where you actually have to skip the
rope twice every time you jump up once
so it's double under the Rope comes
under your feet twice when i started at
crossfit three months ago I couldn't do
them in fact I tried to do them and I
pulled a muscle in my back so I backed
off I started skipping ordinarily with
the intention that eventually I would be
able to do these double unders and you
know I thought about under you know I'm
always thinking of connections between
different things in language learning
and so under in order to do double
unders first of all I went to youtube
and I looked at some videos on how to do
double unders and so the you I first had
to understand how to do double unders
understand almost theoretically by
watching people and then understand that
that my body has to understand it so you
was understand understand how to do
double enders and under um and was no
doubt I had no doubt that I would be
able to do double unders d is dedication
in other words when I am doing the
double unders I'm focusing on my double
unders I'm not thinking of anything else
I am dedicated to the task II is
enjoyment to me it is fun it is fun to
be exercising its apparently double
lenders are good for you stimulate the
brain obviously they're good for various
muscles in your body so enjoy it and
then the r is relax in other words i
think if you're too uptight you won't do
well but if you relax and you just enjoy
it
then you can do the double unders and at
the end of my video here I'll show you a
video of myself doing double unders so
application for language learning you
understand to me the key to improving in
a language is comprehension to
understand when you read and especially
when you listen that's always my number
one focus in language learning if i can
understand i will learn to speak and i
learned to pronounce better if i can
really hear what people are saying and
can understand it and no doubt when i
start a new language i have no doubt
that i will become fluent or fluent
enough in that language to meet my
objectives and there is no end because
once i acquire a new language i expect
to have it with me forever so that's the
end the d again is dedication is so easy
to be distracted look up your twitter
feed look up your email when you when
i'm with my language that's what i want
to be I I feel this is the best place
for me where I want to devote my time
and energy I am dedicated d e I enjoy it
in order to enjoy my language learning I
have to do things that I enjoy doing so
I don't do things like drills and
exercises which I don't enjoy I don't do
you know spaced repetition systems which
I don't enjoy I listen and read and when
the opportunity presents itself I speak
so I enjoy and then finally our relax
relax in the knowledge that you will
eventually get there